I'm Rebecca Hutton and I'm single with
Hollis Street Weaver my granny used to
weave back in the D and make me granny
everybody used to there was a luma if he
hastened practically when I was growing
up the hottest redundancy basically
there's a lot Weaver's and then it
clashed no you get anything and
everything in Hannah Street with the
scooter it's all spillage even if one
side of it dips are either the rest will
keep it going
everybody needs each other I've lined
the nose for yarn and finishing they
rely on Weaver structure make the cloth
team so it's this corporation that you
need but they're not so big thing in the
islands anyway sorry traditionally
I'm on Matty Henderson my dad is away
you go you gave that job to know like a
bad title second season everything so I
kind of feel like there's a vegetarian I
just love working tweet along feel of it
I just love how voters employ a lot of
people we will come back to feed being a
stable employer the time do not for
quite a long time
hardest weeds can only be woven in the
Outer Hebrides you know all these
regulations to mean it can't be taken
anyone else we can't lose it and other
people can fly in just you know they can
make something that looks kind of like
artist weeds but it'll never be Hardesty
it's has to go through the nose and
attach to get that stamp on it to be
part of sweet you might have a hard day
at work you know things might be going
wrong and everything else but it's still
a pretty big job
I just love the thirsty that goes with
her I love the processes that go worth
but I love seeing import process from
beginning to end
you know I mean my dad had she always
had sheets but I was younger and you see
him she adding and everything but you
never knew really what happened to the
rule after that and then you see all the
processes that the rule goes through and
then it goes all over the world and I
love that you know something that we
mean for some when I someone does
something with it you know it's gonna be
some red it's gonna have a story to it
sometime and it will be around still in
years to come
[Music]
my name is Colin George Pokemon I'm
third generation Harris Tweed Weaver is
because of Harris Tweed we were able to
live back to his fudge and community and
from I'm a crafter to you
i I've got the pretty news and sees
beside us you know a lot of our sheep
are in the islands and we practically
live in ports at this time of the year
it's no open Atlantic III behind the
islands and neck stops America really
being in a community you have to get
involved a lot of different things I
hear from grave-digging 3 whatever it be
come here to ask for a hands or whatever
so that's how it always was and there's
more young people are getting into it
especially with downturn in the oil
while workers were paid off have gone
out and bought new moons a lot of people
think we just jumped on the lemon juice
pedal away and operated doesn't work out
like that just won't get the confidence
of it can't be taken off these islands
it's part of the heritage here summer on
the crest of a wave at the moment it's
good very very very Christian long may
it continue the Harris Tweed wave is
part of our heritage and the pride of it
and it very dirty and just trying to
keep the old traditions going for the
wine will be able to
[Music]
[Music]